talk's cheap right we've talked a lot
and we've talked a bunch and gotten
ourselves right to where we are so um in
a moment like this i say hell with the
talking and i'm gonna do more i'm gonna
work harder and um if you're a young guy
looking for somebody to to figure it out
and how to do it uh yeah look at me and
some of these other guys because that's
exactly what we're doing is putting our
head down focusing and uh doubling down
on ourselves
hashtag prescott letting it be known
that talk is cheap and uh i don't know
gujjar gets a little bit of shade at
ownership that keeps talking and talking
and talking and talking i mean they just
got to get out there and they got to
play and they got to win thursday night
they've been playing that game now it
seems like ever since thursday night
football became a regular thing the
short week thanksgiving game thursday
night game the week after that it has
involved the cowboys and they got the
bears and they have to go to soldier
field for that one uh and and that look
the cowboy
chris i talked about this last hour the
cowboys are gonna potentially win that
division at eight and eight or nine and
seven yeah they're gonna be hosting a
team that is 13 and three quite likely
yeah no uh it is uh unbelievable that
they're still in this and of course that
the eagles are still in this and then
the chicago bears on top of that who are
on the wild card you know are on the
outside looking in right now in the wild
card teams that we've gone
a lot of hours of talking about where
there's just dysfunction or things that
are not good about the team and yet here
they are in the nfc they still got a
chance and somehow some way and the
dallas cowboys losing three out of the
last four
and this is a dangerous game this week
now they're better than the chicago
bears you know that but this chicago
bears defense is still a force to be
reckoned with and they you know they're
one strip sack fumble away or an
interception pick six or something like
that and all of a sudden you're gonna be
in a dogfight and on the road in chicago
and cold weather and all those things i
mean uh this is a very very scary game
for the dallas cowboys who
are trying their best to find ways to
lose games uh on a week out week weekend
week out weight basis right now
but they still have a one game lead over
the eagles who have not looked good
lately and and they hold the
head-to-head tiebreaker because they
beat philly earlier this year chris
though and this dawned on me yesterday
the way it's kind of playing out is if
the cowboys win at philly week 16 and
lock up the division they can treat week
17 like a buy they can rest all their
starters they can get ready for the wild
card round when they will be hosting
most likely the loser of the seahawks
49ers
bloodbath 17 with the one seed of the
two seed on the line and the loser has
to go play a cowboys team that's going
to be able to rest at starters who knows
what happens there and we're going to
have we're going to have a renewal of
the complaints that come up from time to
time you're going to have a
a 7-9 or 8-8 team hosting a 13-3 or 12-4
team in the wild card round horribly
unfair but that's the nfl system and
they aren't going to change it no
they're not because you know that i mean
that you know again winning your
division is one of the first goals for
every football team to start the season
so
there has to be some reward for doing
that and yeah it's a little unfair at
some years and this just happens to be
one of those years no doubt about it um
but to your point in what you're saying
with dallas and the whole week 17 and if
that does you know come to fruition
where they basically get a bye week
before the wild card game i mean dallas
is still dangerous
that that's what's that's what's crazy
about dallas yeah they lost three of
their last four probably would have lost
four to their last four if matt stafford
played against the lions but they still
are going to be a tough out because
they're so talented on both sides of the
football they just got to figure out the
formula that works for them to win
football games right now and the first
thing i would say is they're a little
bit past happy that's the thing that
bothers me the most about the dallas
cowboys and their attack we know we
talked about it last week in the new
england game where it was there to be
had again in the run game i think last
week they got away from it it's too much
play action pass it's run for eight
yards and then on second down we're
gonna do play action pass every time or
it's going to be play action pass play
action pass which i love because this is
something that they have not done in
years past but now they've gone
overboard with it and they have a
hundred million dollar offensive line
and 100 million running back and they
don't lean on them enough in my opinion
yeah i i agree with you and you know
they're trying to retool this offense
kind of on the fly and kellen moore
trying to diversify it and sometimes you
can go too far yeah one way and get away
from what made your team what it was and
you know i don't know ezekiel we still
are waiting for him to really break out
and and maybe it's just not going to
happen this year at some point the fact
that he wasn't around for training camp
in the preseason could benefit him
because he may be a little fresher when
everybody else is worn down enough talk
though about the team that is locked in
at the number four seed how about the
saints now the number one seed amazing
accomplishment right after two
consecutive years of heartbreaking
playoff exits they have emerged from
this morass of great teams and i guess
it's not really a morass it's a great
collection i need a better adjective it
is an incredible array of great teams
and the saints are sitting pretty at
number one and they got the 49ers coming
to town look
we've been spoiled by some great games
yeah late in the season right how about
49ers saints this weekend yes with the
number one seat on the line depending
upon what happens with the seahawks on
sunday night at home against the rams
you're on the road rather against the
ramp yeah right well i mean the two
things i mean another bloodbath here for
the san francisco 49ers can they come
out and play you know for the second i'm
not going to count the green bay game
because they physically dominated and
they can basically they took their foot
off the gas pedal in the fourth quarter
but last week is as physical as it gets
it's maybe the two most physical teams
in football the saints and the seahawks
are the other teams that would be right
up there in that conversation if not one
and two themselves so now the 49ers got
to go on the road to new orleans i mean
one thing i respect the hell out of with
sean payton and that group down there
man do they hit and they want to beat
the crap out of you up front on both
sides of the ball and i really love that
the 49ers the same way can they answer
the bell again going cross country
having to make that trip play in that
environment all that and at the same
time yes you're right the saints are
sitting there
but like the saints haven't overly
impressed me lately either the saints
haven't played a really quality football
team in a long time that's the thing
that jumps out to me i mean let me just
mention since they played the dallas
cowboys and won 12 to 10 okay
mike since then and we're seeing that
dallas maybe is not that quality as
we've seen here it's the bucks it's the
jags it's the bears it's the cardinals
it's the falcons it's the bucks it's the
panthers so this is there and then of
course the falcons on thanksgiving
this is their first like i want to say
just top quality team they've had a play
in a long long time but i'm i'm
intrigued to see how they answer answer
the bell here
and the 49ers won't be going
cross-country they're doing what they
did earlier this year when they had
back-to-back games in tampa and
cincinnati they stayed in ohio that week
they're staying in florida this week oh
i didn't know that i mean the games of
baltimore and the games in new orleans
and i talked to kyle shanahan after that
after the win over cincinnati the second
of those two games right and he said
look he explained it to his guys they
bought in you know it's it's it's an
inconvenience it's a sacrifice to be
away for a full week but they understand
the value of it and he said he didn't
believe it until they did it how it
keeps their body clock where it needs to
be and they they're not in a funk early
in the game and for as intense as last
week's game was and as intense as this
week's game is going to be
any little edge helps and you know that
could be the difference between winning
losing and you're right the saints have
not been
dominant everybody that stretched last
year where they were just flat out
dominant they have not done that this
year and uh i think they're going to be
in trouble this weekend at home against
the 49ers they have not seen a team like
the 49ers yet this year no they have not
yeah that's what i was going to ask you
you know just i know it's tuesday but
like where where are you leaning in that
matchup and your tuesday crystal ball
your your gut your spaghetti and
meatballs italian hey i'm micah florio
how's your gutter feel
hey i i it feels like the the saints are
gonna pick up their third loss but we
still have a couple of days before we do
the joint megapix podcast and lock in
take our hand off the checker and uh and
uh and hope for the best but you know
look the saints do not have it easy no
they've got the cults coming to town
after this one they have to go to
tennessee where uh the titans are in no
they never die right
week 17 at the panthers hey carolina's
gonna it's a rematch of that great game
we saw and and you're gonna have ron
rivera trying to make a great closing
argument for himself to keep his job and
you're gonna have guys that are gonna
love to be able to screw things up for
the saints if they could keep them from
earning a buy and you know
there's there's still 25 of the season
to go there's a lot to be determined
there's a lot of great football games to
come but as of right now saints won
seahawks 2 packers 3
cowboys four 49ers five and viking six
and i look i know the rams are right
there yeah i really feel like those are
gonna be the six teams the question is
how do the seeds all figure out yeah i i
feel like that as well i do feel like
it's gonna be those six i would not be
shocked if the rams
beat the seahawks this week at home just
to shake things up i mean we could go
through another total shake-up again
here you know after this week's over
where all of a sudden the 49ers are back
to the one seed and the saints are the
two seed and seattle's down to five i
mean uh i do think the rams match up
very well with the seattle seahawks and
can give them a tough time you know and
they got their mojo back a little last
week on the offensive side of the ball
with jared goff and those things and
then of course seattle's past is
something to worry about so you know
that that'll be a close football game
now you know you could certainly argue
the rams should have beat the seahawks
the first time around on that thursday
night game up in seattle where they
missed a really a very makeable field
goal but the nfc is so intriguing i
think i wanted to be these six teams too
because i do believe they're the six
best this year and i always root for the
six best to get in because i want the
best tv viewing possible when it comes
january and i want to see the best
match-ups and the toughest games and i
think this will lay it out there for us
if we see these six in it
when we return a team that will not be
playing in january who has a highly paid
quarterback who had a fairly big game in
february a couple of years ago will not
be on the field at least for now in
december that didn't make much sense but
it did if you think about it nick falls
out minchumania back in jacksonville
we'll talk about that when pfd
[Music]
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports